yeah
yes i'm continuing
don't know you can't cancel me no
no this is for science i'm doing this
for science
we have to finish we have to finish we
have to first off i want to make some
changes my man rasputin gotta go ate
here for those of you who don't know
this guy was fed cyanide and his food
and drink showed no symptoms so he then
was shot but that wasn't enough to stop
him so he started fighting back against
whoever shot him chased him out then
eventually got shot again
but then they thought he was dead but
apparently that was not it when they did
the autopsy on rasputin or rasputin he
didn't die from the sinai he didn't die
from the bullet wounds he died from
drowning because they threw his dead
body in the river
that's definite at day two i also kind
of want to move up the lawyer guy
because it's so funny the fact that he
won the case
so this guy tried to prove how his
client was innocent because you could
have just so easily shot yourself he
tried to prove that you can shoot
yourself by accidentally shooting
yourself and he died but he won the case
it's a happy story he won case so here
we go here we continue don't cancel me
cancel science cancel history okay well
i'm definitely not reading some of these
[Laughter]
michael goodwin a criminal convicted
murderer was initially given a death
sentence of elect through fusion before
being re reduced to life in imprisonment
instead goodwin then died from
electrocution
when he bit into the wires while
attempting to fix a broken television
set at the same time sitting on a metal
toilet in his presence here
jesus christ wait
that's some final fantasy [ __ ] is that
what it's called not there no it's not
final fantasy final destination what's
wrong with you felix
that's definitely seat here i like that
you can't escape death
a worthy mention this guy was so excited
about jumping out with a parachute that
he forgot to wear the parachute
are you kidding me so he was carrying
video equipment and i guess he mistook
it for a parachute that's just sad i
don't like that but it's kind of kind of
funny it's kind of fun oh my god daniel
john o'brien committed by living by
jumping into a british airway 747 engine
naked scaled two fences with barbed wire
on top fought off four security guards
and commandeered a four-wheel drive
vehicle which he drove into the jet
sitting on the runway with his engines
running
i gotta commend his
his will to die i gotta say oh oh no
it's a sad story
[Laughter]
no
no 38 year old gary hoy a lawyer in
toronto fell from the 24th floor of the
toronto dominion center jesus christ
while demonstrating that its windows
were unbreakable he threw himself
against one which true to his assertion
did not break but instead popped out of
its frame ah that's so cruel why is life
so cruel hey look unbreakable windows oh
god [ __ ] damn it i wonder what that
that's what he thought what do you think
when that happens i'm like [ __ ]
kidding me
i don't even care about this stupid
glass window
god damn it oh this sucks well at least
i showed them right
am i rating this i think it's pretty
high up
i like it rest in peace gary bless your
soul okay this one is great basil brown
a 40 year old health food advocate
why are health food advocates insane so
he died from liver damage after he
consumed
70 million
units of vitamin a
and around 10
viewers gallons there is 40 liters of
carrot juice over 10 days
so you drank four liters of carrot juice
every day that's not i mean yeah that's
a lot
and then
70 million units of vitamin d turning
his skin bright yellow and the uh oh
which is called keratinosis benign and
reversible medical condition where
excessive dietary results in orange
discoloration
of the skin layer you know these [ __ ]
they tell us oh eat the carrot you'll
see better in the dark that's what they
told me but reality eat carrot and you
become a carrot and i'm not okay with
that so apparently it causes the same
sort of effect as alcohol poisoning
that's kind of crazy
oh my god oh my god an entire football
team of 11
in the dominican public were fatally
struck by lightning while playing the
other team left the scene unharmed
[Music]
are you kidding me it killed all of them
sorcery is often used in the region in
an attempt to influence soccer games
they were tied
stop
there's too much evidence cool i believe
in witchcraft now thanks thanks a lot
let's see
bro i'm reading all of these stories and
there's so many young ones that are so
like random just makes you think just
life man
it could end at any moment oh my god
i've heard about this one i don't even
want to read it because it's so gross
but i remember
kids told me about this in school that
there was this guy who volunteered
himself for a cannibal to eat him
and then the cannonball became a
vegetarian in prison good for him
[ __ ] out god damn it oh my god some
of these are just tragic i don't i don't
want to read it
i've heard about this one too
i don't want to read it because it's so
gross stop it the guy that keep being
poo poo with the horse then of course we
have you know i'm not going to rape but
s t or legend suburban rest your soul
jesus christ so this woman was just
minding her own business on a boat and a
[ __ ] giant-ass stingray this [ __ ]
just leaped out of her hit her head
instantly killing her but the stingray
died as well
good [ __ ] you stingray i had enough of
yet the race are protected in florida
that waters yeah well they can't protect
themselves from themselves
idiots bro there's way too many young
people on this list guys don't die
please
okay well this is a classic one and you
know i hear people reference this all
the time like a fun little fact hey did
you know did you know did you know did
you know so i don't think i can get
cancelled anymore because people say
this story all the time about how the
owner of the segway died of a segway
jimmy hasselton 62 died after apparently
riding a segway system off a cliff he
was just trying to allow a man walking
his dog to pass him
so the dog killed him not the segway
thanks dogs
i have never riven ridden a segway and i
will never need to ride a segway
thank you modern technology thank you
for nothing as always hey remember those
casey neistat walking things that
everyone had for a minute why
can we stop inventing things
that doesn't help anything i can walk
you understand this
i don't
i don't get it all right i guess this is
such a famous one and he gets on the
list and everyone did you know do you
agree divorce sure
i'm sorry what
oh this is so creepy father bites his
own son for being possessed by a snake
okazaki city a 23 year old was killed at
the hands of his own father
investigation showed the victim was
assaulted which included head button and
biting the father having been arrested
confess that he did it to drive the
snake that had possessed him
apparently the son was acting violent
and erratic
saying that he was a snake
and the dad was trying to drive the
snake out of him
this sounds like some zuma
i don't like it
no
this is creepy uh a dog ran over a man
in a car okay what the [ __ ] uh someone
died from a beaver because he tried to
pick up the beaver to take a selfie with
the beaver don't do that don't do that
don't pick up beaver with selfie jesus
christ god so many of these just makes
me so uncomfortable like this person
died from cryotherapy machine set to the
wrong level eliminate the oxygen in the
chamber it's like it feels too much like
final fat destination final fantasy i
don't like it i don't like it stop it oh
my god 54 year old man died after eating
a bag of black licorice every day for a
few weeks
see i knew black licorice wasn't
actually like it's actually bad for you
a bag and a half
that's not that doesn't sound like that
much right it caused such low potassium
levels that his heart stopped licorice
contain
an acid i know it imbalances your
hormones too yeah as someone who loves
black licorice i could easily eat a bag
and a half hang on
damn
damn i can't believe that man just like
black licorice man okay we did it thank
you for watching this series check out
the other episodes i'm done okay
i'm done i'm not pushing my luck any
further this is it a lot to learn a lot
to live appreciate life go outside have
fun
bye you thought it was gay
but true relevance never really died
welcome to the first undead game use any
item in your inventory and make memes
inside tuber simulator add some of our
patented stickers in there stickers our
emotions memes our emotions express your
emotions with me
show them for likes share them for love
get up for free
and who knows
maybe i'll review your memes the
greatest honor of all time full circle
baby download it make a meme
we need subtitles on this